chair we're
live now just got the meeting okay
good morning and happy new year to you
all welcome to timbridge district
council's
virtual planning committee on tuesday
the 19th of january 2021
i am your chair mike
all participants here are taking part
remotely
and the committee is being viewed online
and recorded
so please bear this in mind throughout
the meeting
in the event of a break in the internet
connection or a power cut
please bear with us as we try to
reconnect
if we are not able to reconnect after 15
minutes
the meeting will be adjourned and
reconvened at a later date
please check the committee page on our
website for further details
please make sure all microphones are
muted when you are not speaking
to avoid any background noise levels
please keep your points short and do not
interrupt when someone
else is speaking if you wish to comment
please raise your electronic hand
and wait to be called all counselors
have been sent the agenda for today's
meeting
any members of the public who want to
view the agenda
can do so by visiting our website
teambridge.gov dot uk
i will now start the committee by doing
a roll call of everyone here present
when you hear your name please confirm
by saying present
chris thank you chair councillor
bradford
president councillor bellevant
president councillor clarence president
councillor colclough president
councillor hugh cox present
councillor goodman bradbury
present councillor haynes
present councillor hayes
president councillor jackie hook
present counselor mike jeffrey
councillor kurzweil
councillor mcgregor president
councillor natalie
councillor parker present
and councillor patch present
thank you chair that's thank you
everyone okay thank you
i could just introduce the officers who
are here with us today
um there's ros eastman who's the
business manager
for planning uh planning offices we've
got
anna holloway and arta kagula
tree officer mark wadhams the solicitor
there's suzanne wolford i think paul
woodhead may also
be attending and from democratic
services we have chris morgan
and trish corns
okay um first item on the agenda then
is apologies for absence do you have any
apologies please chris
uh there's no apology chair thank you
item two is the minutes of the previous
meeting
which are attached to the agenda is it
your wish that those assigned as a
correct record
yeah i saw admirals uh councillor
kurzweil and councilman
proposing the second does anyone wish to
um say anything con i got a hand raised
there if i could just
uh check on that it's uh council
mcgregor can you
say something please yes thank you chair
um
it was just to to um highlight
um that within the minutes it says that
uh
application 20 oblique 101252
trinity nursery tinmuth was to be
referred
to uh to be fur deferred until the next
committee meeting
i noticed it's not on this particular
agenda and i was just wondering
whether or not we could ask the officers
for an explanation
well obviously perhaps the minute
perhaps should have said to a future
meeting but i mean
there may well be issues that um haven't
been addressed yet
i'll ask um ros eastman to comment on
that please
thank you chair yes it's simply the fact
that the um uh concerns
uh were all the the representation was
received from our colleagues in waste so
late in the day in relation to the time
of committee agenda and then with the
christmas break
and the timetable for hitting this
committee it simply wasn't able
uh we weren't able to get a response and
have that considered by all necessary
parties in time so we are still working
on that and we'll bring it back to
committee as soon as we can
okay so i mean i would suggest that we
amend the minutes to
a future meeting rather than the next
meeting and then that
covers that point with the mover in the
second are we happy with that
i don't know i'm gone yep okay thank you
anybody else
all right can i ask them to save as
spending a long time a show of hands
those in favor please can you raise your
hand
okay that looks um a clear majority and
any were there any against
okay so that's carried right that's the
minutes of the previous meeting
item three declarations of interest i
know of a couple
so members indicate please i want to go
through the list as they're
appearing for me uh councillor natalie
yeah thank you chair um yes application
uh 20 stroke zero one
eight five three uh car wash at
128 was a personal interest as i know
the
applicant and enforcement 20
stroke zero zero one five o
e n f uh chardonnay at um to
woodland um obviously receiving emails
and also
uh knowing the chairman of the council
through being a board member
thank you um councillor bolovant
um application coming in 20 oblique 0209
727 padren road the person who lives
next door to pop is a personal friend
so for that reason i won't take part in
the discussion on that particular item
thank you council branford
thank you chair um after discussion with
the monitoring officer
um i would declare an interest in 5f
so i won't be speaking or voting on on
that agenda item
thank you councillor patch
thank you chair after hearing um
previous
um interests i wonder if clarification
could be forthcoming about um interest
in
in terms of knowing an applicant um
because i i
i do know what one of the applicants but
um
not on a on a sort of close personal
level and indeed not sort of seeing them
so
very often at all but i i i don't
understand that as falling under an
interest to be registered perhaps so we
could have some clarification
okay well i'll ask the um solicitor in a
moment to comment on that my view has
always been if it's somebody you
socialize with always remember it being
described as someone who's
who you would visit their house perhaps
for uh meals
that type of level of socializing is is
the the rule of thumb i've always taken
um can i ask um if our solicitor is able
to comment please
suzanne don't see on the screen
yeah thank you chair um yes it can be
if it's in if it's a a contact that
others might be be if
people might if it might be seen to be
um a close a close
it's a difficult it's it's your call but
you need to consider what it might look
like to others
okay in that regard then i think it's
probably
prudent if i were not to take part in
the item on the car wash
okay thank you so you're declaring an
interest in
in that one yes right that's that's the
end of those people that have indicated
that they wish to declare an interest so
if we could take if it counts as
bradford and patch
take your hands down please electronic
ones
okay nobody else right if we move on
then to
item four public participation
firstly i can advise that there are
members of the public who have
asked to speak on all of the
applications from
b onwards that's the car wash one
and for the rest of those but the other
item that i wish to wish to raise at
this point
uh i think the reasoning will become
clear to you shortly
is i want to vary the order in
enable us to bring forward items six
because
um the officer um
eastman will explain to this there is a
uh a request for this one
both the enforcement items to be
deferred
now given that there are people who are
ward members who may be wishing to speak
and waiting
uh for that until later in the meeting
and there are members of the public who
are wishing to
view that and i think that needs to be
taken now so that committee can make a
decision
on whether to defer the two items uh on
enforcement for the reasons that
rose eastman will outline so can i hand
over to you please ross
thank you chair um it's a fairly
straightforward
well from my perspective is a simple
request really
um following the publication of the
agenda we received legal advice
that it would be in the best interest of
ensuring the robustness of our decisions
in relation to the two enforcement cases
that they should both be withdrawn from
consideration at this committee
we are actively working on next steps um
and on
on bringing them back to committee if
they need to come back at the next
feasible opportunity but
uh there is a change in our
recommendation for each of them that
they should be withdrawn from the agenda
at this time thank you thank you so i'd
move that those two items under
enforcement are withdrawn from the
agenda is that seconded please
second did yes councillor goodman
bradley seconded
but any questions on that uh let's just
see
what uh who's got their hand up um
so i've got councillor natalie yeah so
thank you chair
um yeah obviously i'm disappointed that
this is not coming
up for enforcement i mean i did ask the
question yesterday when it came in at
the very late stage
of why it was being deferred or
recommended for deep parent
um because what i my question was
because of the especially with the
chardonnay one
um you know because of the uh work that
is still going on by
the um owners of the that property
you know what what enforcement is being
taken so that they don't continue with
any work in there thank you can i ask um
ross eastman to come back can you turn
your volume up slightly rose i don't
know if it's it full already or not
sorry i might just need to move my wand
see if that's any better
um so uh the particularly in relation to
chardonnay the reason that that one was
coming to
committee was in relation to um the
uh our scheme of delegation which
suggests that when we're dealing with
enforcement matters relating to
residential occupation it needs to come
to committee that doesn't stop us from
continuing with enforcement action in
relation to other matters at the site
um but we do need committees authority
to
um uh make decisions in relation and
where
a decision could potentially make people
homeless so um
that's not the reason for the deferral
there's it's uh simply uh
in relation to legal advice that we've
received but there is nothing that
should
necessarily stop us apart from clarity
of enforcement processes
from taking enforcement action in
relation to other matters at that site
at the moment
thank you can i just explain to other
members of the committee that ward
members had
been given advanced notification of this
um because obviously the
effect it may have had on their
attendance at the meeting uh
so that they were aware this was coming
up uh councilman colclough
yeah thank you chairman yes i had points
to raise on this because i wasn't
totally happy with the recommendation
of the things that i thought wanted
adding so will that come back to the
committee so that we can make these
points
yes um ca ross easement on two comments
uh as i've just said uh in relation to
specifically the residential
use of the site any unauthorized
residential use of the site that is
something that does need to come to
committee if we want to take action so
at the moment there's no intention to
not bring these
matters both uh back to committee as
soon as it's feasible
okay thank you right so we'll need to
take a vote on this
i moved these items be i can't remember
what the expression was it wasn't
deferred it was
um was it withdrawn i honestly can't
remember which wording i said withdrawn
from today
yeah that's what i i would have used
then thank you and that was seconded
um so can we go for a vote on that
please if i ask chris to
do the roll call please thank you chair
uh councillor bradford
councillor bellevant paul councillor
clarence
councillor cole clough councillor cox
councillor goodman bradbury four
councillor haynes councillor hayes
or councillor jackie hook
counselor jeffrey councillor kurzweil
councillor kurzweil or
councillor mcgregor or
councillor nutley
councillor nuttall
councillor parker four and counselor
patch
four that's carried chair
okay thank you i had the dustbin
collection going on outside so i'm muted
for that bit i think it's gone away now
thank you so that's carried so move on
now to item five
which is the planning applications for
consideration
first one of those is um application
a there are no public speakers that's
the one in powder and road
so i'll go straight over to ross to go
through the presentation on this please
thank you chair uh
chris i'm sorry could you make me
co-host please
yep sorry
try now
thank you that's working that's it just
rearrange my windows okay can you see my
screen
please somebody just quickly confirm for
me yes yes absolutely lovely
thank you um so this application
uh is before you today simply as a
result of the fact that the
owner of the property the subject
property um
is a member of staff here at team bridge
so the application
um seeks permission for uh
apologies seek permission for a first
floor balcony to the rear of the
property
and a change of the windows um from a
window to a french door as it says on
the presentations in front of us
um so if i can just quickly take you
through these
uh slides um you can see
that the property uh is a long narrow
plot the plot
in question and this is on powder road
um
the front of the property faces south
towards padren park
and we're looking at a balcony on the
rear gable here so there is a
reasonably considerable separation
distance heading to the north of the
site
there we are so the existing elevation
you can see here it's a relatively
narrow
um gable extrusion at the back um with a
single story log store
underneath and the window at the moment
and it's quite
tall it's quite long and you'll see on
the photographs shortly that underneath
the mirror
and the window there is an area
of infill at present at the moment upvc
infill
in place the proposal is
that the window be replaced by a
door similar proportions in terms of its
width to the existing window
with a balcony with glass balustrading
underneath it would
um uh extend out the back of the the
gable by
two meters so it's a reasonably sizable
um balcony but
uh still considered to be acceptable and
in proportion
and there's the other side
uh the red arrow here shows the location
of the balcony on
on the rear building and you can see in
this image
the extent of uh windows on the gable
ends of the properties
uh on either side at the moment and also
the existing balcony
and so there is an existing level of
intervisibility between the properties
at the site
and on balance overall officers don't
consider that the
proposed balcony would lead to any
unacceptable additional overlooking or
intrusion of privacy of the neighbours
so the recommendation on this one is one
of approval
thank you okay thank you
um so the um there's no public speaker
so we can go on to the world member
on this one um which is council bradford
i believe
i'm i'm quite happy with that chair
thank you
okay thank you right well as members are
aware it's only before us because of the
fact that it's
um due to being a member of staff
um so anybody else wish to speak
if not i'll i'll move the recommendation
as set out
which um thank you that was
um that was councillor parker
thank you so the recommendation is as on
uh
under item two on the first page of the
written report
okay that's been moved and seconded
nobody else has indicated they wish to
speak so can i ask
chris please to go through the roll call
that permission be granted so it can
indicate for
or against permission being granted
thank you chris
thank you chair councillor bradford for
councillor bullavent
uh this is one he he has been declared
interesting thanks chad
councillor clarence councillor colclough
councillor cox councillor
hayes
councillor hayes
hook counselor jeffrey
councillor kurzweil
councilman mcgregor
councilor nutley or
councillor nuttal or councillor parker
or councillor patch what
uh councillor goodman bradbury four
and councillor haynes that's unanimous
chair
thank you so that's carrier permission
is granted as uh
in the recommendation right moving on
then to
the second item item b the car wash at
128 ashburton road
um we have one public speaker on this
one that's paul parker
can he be admitted to the meeting please
and then i'll ask
um rose to give us the presentation
right i can see that the support is
present
um so um ross can you start please
presentation yes of course
thank you chair uh just hit the right
screen
there we go so uh the application that
we've got before us today
uh is a an application for a variation
of a condition
um in relation to the way that the car
wash
um at 128 ashburton road
currently operates um the suggested
change
uh is that the opening hours would
extend
by an hour at the beginning and end of
every day monday to saturday
and by an hour at the end of the day on
on sundays as well
um there is an objection to this from my
colleagues in environmental health
and as a consequence the recommendation
is um one of refusal we
think that the impacts would be
unacceptable on the surrounding
properties
and this is obviously an area that's
subject to quite a lot of change at the
moment
um you can see from this plan here
that there are the new houses at the uh
start of churkin bridge road just uh in
close proximity
uh and that there are dwellings as well
to the to the rear of the sites
and our environmental health colleagues
are very concerned that any an
increase in noise from the site would be
unacceptable
and they therefore are supportive of our
recommendation to refuse this one
thank you chair all right thank you
you can go back to the normal screen
right
we've got um paul parker supported
please would you
like to speak for the three minutes that
you have
sorry can you hear me yes i can hear you
sorry it's um
that's okay three minutes to start when
you start giving your speech
yeah thank you chairman of members i've
been asked
to speak to you by the operator of the
business as i'm the owner of the
premises
the car wash has been operating those
hours since it was
moved from the back of the site to the
front in 2011.
it appears that the previous owner who
applied for the permission to move the
car wash
he also applied for the car service at
the same time he informed me that he
believed the operating hours that he put
on the application form
were for the new car sales element and
that the car wash hours of seven to
seven
pm seven days a week approved in 1993
would stay the same
as it was only being relocated within
the same site
and this seems to be in a minute of
error
issues only arose from one person in
2016
after the new houses were built opposite
a single objective has stated that noise
is an issue
however the car wash is located on a
very busy road and was already existing
business
before all the houses were built in fact
the garage has been on the site since
the 1930s
following advice from the environmental
health the business owner has lagged the
pipeline to prevent any rattling on the
steel work
rehos the pressure washer into doors
with insulation and has turned down the
pressure on the hand washers
to help mitigate the noise there is
currently a live planning application on
this site for a convenience store that
would operate from 7am to 7pm
11 p.m seven days a week approved by the
council last year
after officers recommended approval the
noise of the comings and going
including large delivery lorries
unloading crates and cages were not
deemed to be an issue with that
application there are two other car
washes that have been approved by
offices in residential areas and newton
average since this one was appear
approved
both use the same process involving
pressure washers
and are located the same distance from
residential dwellings as ours
these are h2o by the hospital opposite
the flats and at melba surrounded by
houses
they have operated in hours of eight
till six and eight till eight seven days
a week respectively
the hour before and after people finish
work are crucial
to the business times being unable to
compete
on a level playing fluid with the other
car washes by having crucial irs reduce
would make the business unviable
particularly in these very difficult
economic times there are five families
that rely on this business for their
income
newton about tone council had no
objection to the monday and saturday
opening hours
of 8 till 6 but would like sunday to
stay the same from nine to four
the operator and i will be willing to
accept this recommendation as an
alternative as a suitable compromise and
the officers have been informed of this
thank you for your time thank you okay
thank you um i've got a question arising
from that um the object sorry the
supporter um
sent me a copy of the speech yesterday
uh so i looked at
the 1993 application
and decision notice um as it was
mentioned in the speech
i didn't see any reference in on the
application form to the hours that were
ended up being approved then but on the
decision notice it did say
7 a.m to 7 00 p.m
so if i could ask rose please to clarify
what the position
is with that because i know i've spoken
to her about this already
ros thank you chad yes so i've had a
look at the planning history on this one
and from what i can see
the 1993 permission relates to a
completely different scheme of
redevelopment of the site with a car
wash facility placed to the rear of the
site
and even screened within some kind of
housing maybe
like the jet wash at sainsbury's in
houston abbott
so it's a completely different set of
circumstances and that planning
permission from what i can see
has never been implemented it's a
different building on site so whilst
that is the hours that were approved
on that scheme uh that's not relevant to
the history that we've got here
uh we have uh a constrained site now
um with uh concerns from our
environmental health colleagues
regarding
noise and that there would be uh
potential
uh some more consent complaints and
possibly uh
even uh statutory nuisance concerns uh
if the
uh opening hours were allowed to be any
longer
um in relation to the amended hours
environmental health would continue to
object as they consider that any
additional
noise at this site would not be
acceptable um
and members may recall that we applied a
series of conditions to the
convenience store planning permission
for the site
regarding um background noise levels uh
delivery methodologies the type of
deliveries that can take place and when
they can take place so
uh it's not not strictly true to suggest
there were no noise concerns related to
the convenience store proposal for this
site
thank you right if i could go on to the
ward member now please councillor
bulovant
uh thank you this particular site has
been
in uh operation for many many years
and it's been used as a garage of four
core
various operations including as a car
wash for many years
and all of these operations pre-date
the building of the new estates that now
surround it
i have a problem therefore where you've
got an existing business
making or operating in the same way that
is done for many years
suddenly being constrained into what it
can do because we've allowed building to
take place around it
equally i recognize that the application
that came forward for
a commercial development that was
approved last year
and operating hours would allow vehicles
to come and go
at significantly longer hours and those
that the
applicants are now looking for
i also note that the people using the
site
have suggested an amendment of the hours
that they would be happy to work with
which which would restrict some of the
hours and on that basis i'd be perfectly
happy to accept their amendment and
recommend that this application gets
approval
thank you so your moving approval with
the
variations amendment yes
that's correct described thank you i'll
second that chairman
it's been seconded by councillor parker
right thank you i've got
um three people to speak now
uh council mcgregor
thank you um chair just bear with me two
seconds after
kicked out of the um the um
system um in terms of the the um
environmental health department um being
consulted on on the
um the planning application they
commented
commented that the statutory noise
nuisance complaints
received in 2017 2018
haven't continued into 2019 2020
which would suggest perhaps that the
efforts made by the
um the applicant
you know to to reduce the the noise uh
appeared to have rectified the issues
that the the environmental health
officer was concerned about because
there was no further issue
raised there in terms of the um
inter
they specifically relate to the the
the adjustments that have been made by
the applicant for those noise complaints
so from my perspective i i think i'm i'm
more than happy to follow
follow councillor bulovan's lead and um
recommend that this is this is approved
with the hours adjustment as
stated by the supporter thank you
councillor natalie thank you chair i
think
everything's been said that i was going
to say i mean i totally agree with
councillor bullock
and councilman mcgregor i mean like we
were saying the garage has been there
since the 1930s
and i mean the road is very busy gets
heavy laura's going through there in any
case
um but you know to have just um
you know two letters from the same
household
um seems to be rather strange that no
other one nobody else has come forward
um to uh to object to this application
um and like like we were saying that uh
should it become a convenience store
again
the arrows will be from seven to eleven
you will be having as the applicant
mentioned that uh you'll be having uh
laura's coming in there uh probably
early hours of the morning maybe to
unload their goods
um to do that um
personally i i have no problems with
this in in being
approved um as i say i i
totally agree with what uh councilman
mcgregor said about the saturday noise
um on that um i don't really think
there's an awful lot more i can i can
add on this and say i
i totally accept what people have said
um but just to have uh
two letters and and and to say
personally
i mean i wouldn't want to drive into
ashburton
and uh have to drive right the other
side of new navit to have my car wash
when i can get it just
within coming into into newton abbott so
um totally agree with the other speakers
and
i will be voting to approve this thank
you thank you
councilman hook thank you um yeah i just
wanted to make a couple of points and
then maybe ask a couple of
questions or clarify a couple of bits of
information um
i know i know the car wash well um i
pass it regularly actually um
that's on one of my regular sort of
cycle routes that i ride
um and so i can i can confirm it is a
noisy operation
but and it's popular and well used um
but with you know i can't um vouch for
how that sounds in somebody's house so i
wouldn't want to
that's not a scientific analysis the
fact that i think it's noisy when i
pass by um and also i was going to say i
don't
believe the other two car washes that
were referred to
by the um supporter um
are as close to residential property so
the h2o
car wash at the bottom of jetty marsh
road is not as near to residential
properties as this one is
and equally the milva one isn't either i
i know that one well that's the garage
i'd take my car to um and that is a
quieter operation the one
mil where it's a different different set
of equipment it is very quiet i've stood
near it while it's operating it's not
noisy in the same way um so just to
clarify those bits of information
i don't believe it's um unfair that
those have different
operating hours because they are
differently located
with regard to residential properties um
but what i
wanted to clarify was um in relation to
points other people have made
so um regarding the fact that complaints
don't seem to have been made to
environmental health since 2017
i mean is that because people gave up
they didn't feel that it was worth
complaining anymore
because their you know their complaints
hadn't been taken into account
or is it because the um
owner has managed to deal with those
noise complaints and they are no longer
there i mean that
that i think we need to clarify because
that's an important piece of information
and equally i was um wanting to clarify
if this letter of consultation did go to
all surrounding neighbors
then if there is um ongoing um feelings
that the noise is too much
then it is surprising that we've only
had two letters from one
residential property so perhaps can we
clarify
who was consulted um you know was it all
immediate neighbours
and did we not have a response from them
because i think that does
lead to my supporting of the the
proposal by
um councillor bullock thank you thank
you
right um well obviously i'll ask ross to
come in a minute and
we'll go through um what the conditions
would be
um i'd i'll be voting against um
approval because i still see that if our
environmental health department has
objected to this then i would uh support
that view
but i note that there are a number of
members who are supportive of this
so if i could ask roz to just clarify
what
the hours would be um
with the proposal that's before us for
for approval and any other conditions
and if i could ask councillors bullivant
and parker
uh to uh if they're in agreement with
that roz
thank you chair and so the hours that
have been um
put to us uh as the alternative to those
that were applied for
are eight or six uh let me just make
sure i've got this absolutely clear
uh eight till six um monday to saturday
and nine till four
on sundays um
that's the suggestion that's what we're
um now i think being asked to consider
and environmental health have been
consulted specifically on that
um and they have suggested that they do
uh still consider that that
it would increase the impact on on
neighboring properties and they're not
happy
in their consultation response so the
environmental health team did say that
if we were going to
approve this application they would like
to see
the erection of acoustic barriers and
and that's something that we've really
struggled with in terms of advising the
applicant previously because the the
visual impact of any barriers that could
be acceptable
has been from a noise perspective has
been unacceptable from a visual
perspective
and they would also ask there would be
no activity on site
before 8th or after 6 and no machinery
to be used on site before 9 a.m so it'd
be hand car wash only
and they'd also like the submission of a
noise management plan
now we haven't worked that up into
formal conditions
yet so if we were going to
be approving this with those broader
hours then
i would um ask for your delegated
authority please to
um work out what those
terms would look like as enforceable
planning conditions so delegated
authority to build the environmental
health recommendations into enforceable
planning conditions for the site
thank you okay would that be delegated
in consultation with
the chair and vice gerald ward member
if members consider that necessary then
yes of course
thank you right can i ask councillor
bullavent first if
you'd be content with the conditions
that have been outlined
thank you subject your additional
comments about being involved in the
discussion yes i am happy
thank you and um council parker would
you be content with that
yes i'm totally happy with that chairman
totally okay
okay so um it's clear what
ros eastman just said and then it would
be um delegated in consultation with
chair vice chair and board members
of those conditions relating to the
acoustic barrier
okay nobody else has indicated they wish
to speak
so the motion before us it's been moved
approval
with the conditions just described by
ros eastman
so can i ask chris please to go through
the
vote on this thanks chair can i just
check quickly before the vote
who's not voting on this item because
they've declared an interest
i think councilman nutley did would it
count um
councilman patch was it counseling
luckily as well
i i declared a personal interest knowing
the applicant but
that didn't restrict me from voting
right okay
thank you right thank you
councillor bradford oh
councillor bellavent
counselor clarence councillor colclough
councillor cox or
councillor um hayes
jeffrey councillor kurzweil
cool councilman mcgregor
or councillor nutley or
that's the nuttle or councillor parker
or councillor goodman bradbury
and councillor haynes again
that's carried chair thank you so that
permission has been granted with those
conditions
as outlined right and give um we could
see that counselor the public speaker
has
left please and then the next item we're
moving on to is the
the um mulberry street in tinmuth
we have um an objector to this one
so can we be sure that the object has
been admitted before we continue
um chris can i confirm that the one
that's the who are we one that's showing
up at the bottom of my
participant screen is that the objector
yes i
believe so can i just check please
hello hello caroline yeah hello thank
you
is that that's carol that's that's with
us then is it going it is
very very strange state of affairs isn't
it right
okay if i could ask you to mute please
again now and then
i'll go through the officer presentation
and then i'll be inviting you
to speak after that thank you
okay so this is the um land adjacent to
six mulberry street tinmuth
so if i could ask roz please to do the
presentation on that one
thank you chair um this is a um
an alternative uh application uh to
when the one that members may recall
from um uh
early in 2020 um uh
for two dwellings in timmus on
a site um that is uh
relatively close to you to the railway
line and
close to the town centre um members will
note from the update sheet a number of
changes to the report where we
erroneously and accidentally referred to
the previous scheme for which my
apologies
um but the scheme that uh we are looking
to grant permission today is the one
that's illustrated
on this presentation that's before us
now so
you can see uh that it's largely um
uh the same or certainly very similar to
the the
previous scheme uh two dwellings
semi-detached dwellings fronting onto
mulberry street and this time with a
small gable to the rear
um but what has changed from the
previous scheme
is that the um scheme no longer includes
a third story or a room in the roof
of the dwelling to the south of the site
it's now just a straightforward
two-story dwelling um and the gable ends
to the
south apologies my scrolling is um
jumping a bit quickly at the moment and
the gable to the south
uh no longer includes the three juliet
or the
three tall windows and the juliet
balconies
so the scheme uh is a
modified scheme compared to that that
members considered previously
and members should be aware from having
read the report
that um planning permission was granted
for the previous scheme
um by the planning and inspectorate um
at appeal so
this is a uh from our perspective
um sufficiently similar that there there
would be no reason for refusal
uh that that would overcome the the
granting of the permission that was um
made by the planning inspectorate and if
anything it would have a
lesser impact than the previous scheme
in relation to a number of the matters
that were concerned with members
as that room in the roof has now been
removed
thank you chair
all right thank you go back to the other
screen right
thank you can i then invite um the
objector caroline to speak for three
minutes please
if you could unmute and then the time
will start when you start speaking
can you hear me now yes good thank you
and thank you again for giving me the
opportunity to object to the proposed
development in mulberry
street i am representing numbers one to
four westcliff heights and also 43 and
44
parsons street sadly the owner of 45 was
recently deceived
um may i say that this is the fourth
time i've now had to attend the planning
committee meeting with regard to this
development
and the developer again has made some
tweaks to his application
this is severely affecting the mental
health and well-being of the above
residents who are predominantly
shielding because of their ages
and because they are all because they're
registered disabled we're completely
stressed out by this bombardment of
applications and it's affecting our
day-to-day living
um we appreciate that the developer took
this to appeal despite the council
uh rejecting his um his application um
and this is just unfortunate the tweaks
that he has made this time are a little
more
um a little less incumbent on us but
however
i would still draw your attention to the
fact that the town council
unanimous unanimously refused uh
recommended refusal of this development
um several times again um and
they asked this to come under category
fee to the planning committee
we feel that the parish council know the
area better than most
and i would please ask you to listen to
them and reject this planning
application
the two proposed dwellings will
significantly still
overlook 43 and 44 parsons street
and you know that their light will be
significantly diminished
miss pringle of number 43 is registered
disabled
and has a condition which will continue
to deteriorate over the
years and she's extremely concerned
about the lack of light
and being overlooked i would also add
that previous extensions have been
refused for number 44
and also 1a and 1b mulberry street
who sought similar permissions for that
height
there in in our opinion there is already
significant over-development in the area
currently there's a very large block of
apartments being built on the site of
the old job centre
there is some limited parking with this
development however there are also ten
existing
apartments in clay lane with no parking
there are eight public spaces in parson
street these are constantly full
and there is illegal parking at all
times of the day and night if you went
there now you see that people were
illegally parking
therefore the proposed two three-bedroom
family homes
and these are family homes will have at
least one vehicle
and i feel like the assumption that
development is in with
reasonable walking distance to car parks
and that the occupiers could manage
without a car
it's just unfounded and my final point
or our final point is that parson street
is a single
road vehicle road leading directly to
our access lane which then narrows
from 19 foot to 13 foot six and serves
four properties
we have five vehicles and a mobility
scooper
scooter access is required at all times
yeah that's time
okay can you wrap up please yeah yeah
certainly it's
just that we are just concerned about
the parking thank you
thank you uh the building i should say
sorry okay
thank you right um now
we don't have a world member present
there was previously a site
inspection on this site for the earlier
application
and i went on site
i didn't have any i couldn't find any
planning reasons at that time
that i could see as reasons for refusal
but the committee refused it
the important point though is that it
was approved
at appeal and as has been said by
roz this scheme if anything is is
certainly
um no worse than um in the eyes of
um those who would be unhappy with it
than the one that has been approved at
appeal
in fact is slightly uh improved shall we
say
so given that the size of the footprint
and the heights and everything else are
as before
i can't see any reason myself uh for
refusal and i will be supporting the
recommendation i have now somebody
indicated to speak
and that's uh councillor hook
thank you chad i mean i i follow your
reasoning i don't know the site
but um yeah your reasoning is sound in
a previous application that would have
more impact has
um been approved on appeal um but i was
going to um flag up the fact that this
report
and something has changed i think since
the last application in that we now
um have a new carbon calculator
that we should be applying to all new
development um
and that doesn't take in to account now
where
where the development is located as it
did previously
the policy s7 must be purely satisfied
by the building
structure itself um and that
i can't um see anything in the report
that refers to
the carbon reduction of this development
so i'm just flagging that up i can see
all the reasoning but
um you know this is something we should
now be considering every single
property that gets built now should be
um
fulfilling policy s7 with our new carbon
calculator since
october 2019 so um
i welcome a comment on that thank you
thank you
ross
thank you chair um i think uh it's
probably fair to say
that in light of the the previous
permission on this site that is
something that has probably been
overlooked
um by officers here and this is a
brownfield land with modern dwellings in
a sustainable location
and in terms of uh minimizing the carbon
uh generated by the development you
couldn't get
much better uh just from a
straightforward development of this
nature
it's also important to note the
differential between um
major projects which uh are required to
submit the carbon reduction fan to us
and
minor applications where we are seeking
to uh minimize
the carbon footprint so on balance and
overall i think um
uh that your counselor hook is right we
need to make sure that that
sentence is included or the analysis is
included in every one of our reports
i think applying a different set of
conditions to this um permission would
uh potentially be seen as unreasonable
by a by an inspector
and given the scale of the development i
consider that it's appropriate as it is
thank you councilman did you want to
come back on that
yeah i did i mean that isn't the correct
analysis of the situation since 2019
every application that's submitted
um for development um does need to
satisfy
policy s7 and em3 according to our new
carbon calculator which does not take
into account
the location of a development um so
so that isn't the correct analysis um i
don't
believe it can be dismissed that easily
um
you know we put these policies in place
because we have a climate emergency and
um
you know that's why i'm going to flag it
up every single time
without fail i'm afraid thank you
council mcgregor
thank you chair um i'm i'm going to
repeat comments that i made on the the
application when it
came and was refused the last time
there's there's a fundamental error in
the way that this is being presented
as a brownfield site when it's actually
pdl
previously developed land and it was
quite some time ago this is not
a brownfield site that happened a few um
years ago
this is more than seven decades
you know ago so from my perspective i
think you know describing it as
brownfield land gives an impression that
it's
a bit of scrub land that could be easily
developed and that the parking element
still is a massive question there are
fundamental
um i don't want to use the word
dishonesty but
there is a fundamental um mis
picturing if you like of the of the
parking situation
in that area there are no spare parking
spaces in those streets at all the
nearest
parking spaces are either polysteps or
at
behind the the blue anchor they are some
considerable distance walking
away from those particular homes if
they're built
there is there is no you know there's
there's no kind of
mentality nowadays for people not to
have cars
people want cars if you want to get to
anywhere
you have to have a car the the transport
system
is not really that well integrated
so you know the the portrayal of it
being oh you know it's fine there'll be
you know it'll be parking they could
park in the car parks the park
car parks cost money you know people
won't want to do that so where are they
going to park
they're going to park on double yellow
lines and or in
other people's parking spaces and that's
a fundamental missed picture
that's been presented regarding the
parking and i actually think we didn't
possibly present to the planning
inspector a robust enough case
for these uh for the refusal first time
round
thank you okay councillor branford
councilman branford
thank you sorry i was just trying to on
you um
i did go to the site visit last time and
the access to this piece of land is
dreadful
absolutely awful uh i'm just
um speechless that the planning
inspector
passed it um and
there is overlooking and i i just think
that um all the reasons that
councillor mcgregor just gave as well
the parking
so um i'm i wouldn't be mine to pass
it okay thank you councilman clarence
uh yeah chair it's with heavy heart that
i have to
try and agree with you um if i were to
vote against this and this council
were to refuse this application which i
probably think we
should probably be doing would the
council be
deemed to be acting unreasonably in view
of the count and view of the inspectors
to the
decision to grant at appeal
would the cre this council be acting
unreasonably and therefore be vulnerable
to costs
if we were to refuse this application
could the officers answer that okay well
i
thought you might have been making a
rhetorical question but i'll ask
roz or um suzanne
to answer that one please
i'll take that one chair thank you um
my advice would be that we would be very
vulnerable to costs
and the schemes are sufficiently similar
the circumstances around each of the
schemes is sufficiently similar that
that
reaching a different conclusion within
um months of the decision receiving the
decision from the inspectorate would
be highly likely to be considered
unreasonable um by the planning
inspectorate
uh you know their their their
circumstances haven't changed there's
been no material change in circumstances
that would support um a refusal of a
scheme on this site
thank you councilman
yeah i agree with all all that reasoning
i mean um
yeah i don't have a problem with houses
being built here
and um i think we have to bear in mind
the planning history of this site and
the fact that the
site was given of approval on appeal so
i don't have a problem with that my only
suggestion would be is that we defer so
that we can have a proper
look at um how the the
development conforms to policy s7 and
en3 that would be my only suggestion but
um i i think it would be foolish myself
to
to refuse this as it stands
in considering its planning history i
mean i'm happy to recommend that we
defer in order to get a proper analysis
of the
carbon reduction properties of this um
application
well i was going to move approval as set
out
so i'm i'm not about to to second
deferment
um because i think that the explanation
given and um obviously the history of it
from the recently approved one from the
inspector
then i i can see no other thing to do
so the absence of any one
second in jackie can i move the
recommendations set out please he's
saying
second jackie you're saying oh sorry
you're second in jackie foreign
okay so motion is for a deferment
um i'd move an amendment then that it be
approved as set out
is that seconded i second that thank you
so that's sent in by council government
bradbury so
those are the emotions that uh
we have before us nobody else has
indicated they wish to speak
i think i've just got jackie with her
hand up again
um okay so can we go to the vote so
we'll take the amendment
first the amendment is that it be
approved
as set out so can you please vote for
against or abstain on the permission be
granted
as set out chris thank you
chair councillor bradford thanks
councillor bullavent that's the clarence
against councillor colclough
four councillor cox
uh four councillor hayes against
answer hook that's the jeffrey
councillor kurzweil paul
councillor mcgregor against
councillor nutley against
councillor nettle against councillor
parker
against councillor pax
councillor goodman bradbury
four and councillor haynes
chair that's a tool thank you so
i'll use my casting vote in favor of the
amendment
so for so the amendment's carried so the
motion before us we'll have to vote
again on this
the motion becomes the permission be
granted
as set out that's the the amendment that
became
passed can i ask chris to go through the
vote again please
thank you chair um can you say that
again please mike
yes the the amendment was successful it
won on a casting vote there were eight
votes each
it was tied but i gave the casting vote
in favor of the amendment
so the amendment which is now the
substantive motion
is that permission be granted um
as set out with the conditions that are
listed
at the top of page 20 i've lost it now
sorry there we are
um the top of page 25 so it's
permission to be granted with the ten
conditions listed there
okay so if you can vote on that please
chris will call your name
so it's permission be granted as the
motion
how's the bradford
hayes against councillor hook
counselor jeffrey councillor kurzweil
counselor mcgregor against
councillor nutley against
council nuttall against councillor
parker
against councillor patch or
councillor goodman bradbury four
and councillor haynes
it's the same scorcher so it's eight
votes for
eight against so i'll use the casting
vote for so
permission is granted as set out
okay can we move on then please that
took the mouse the public speaker is
moved to the waiting room and if we
could have the
next two public speakers for the
application
d golden sounds in dualish can they come
into the
meeting please
so i can
i think i can see both of them we have
the um
supporter ian butter and then there's
phillips ka i believe is the
objective is that right chris
that's correct yeah okay thank you
um so this is the one at golden sands in
dualish
um if i can just bring up the
screen myself um
and what i forgot to ask the officer
is whether this is a major or or not
in terms of the land because it will be
five minutes or
or the lesser amount oh and i have got
um one to read out myself so there's a
document that's been sent in from
objectors from local residents which
i'll be reading out so i presume this is
a major if we've got
um people can i just have some guidance
please
um from the officer i've got to ask this
one
how much time overall we've got on
on each of those yeah there'll be five
minutes each
for the objectives of the objector and
their statement
and then there will be 10 minutes for
the
um the supporter in order to balance
that out okay thank you that's that's
what i thought would be the case that's
that's fine so we have the um
one supporter speaking uh will come
second but there are
uh there's an objector in the meeting
and i have
a document to read out from another
group of objectors
okay um so this is anna
going through this one hopefully anna's
there with us somewhere
and all the way yep there she is over to
you anna
bring up the presentation i think you
need to
turn your volume up slightly please
is that better chair slightly
okay i've got the presentation
okay so this is a proposal for the
change of use of the land for the site
of the stationing of static holiday
caravans with the accompanying detail
showing a scheme for 42 pitches
along with associated works including
ground works
with changes levels areas of hard
standing access road
and details of landscaping and the
relocation of existing children's play
area
and associated equipment onto adjoining
land at the golden sands and peppermint
park
holiday park in dallas warren
so the the blue line shows the the wider
holiday park and the red line shows the
area of the application site
we can see here the properties along
mount pleasant
road adjacent to the site and the site
in its wider setting
with doris warren
if we just go through to one of the
closest shots we can see the existing
access road that runs through the site
and the children's play area which is to
be located
onto the land here
this is the indicted site layout
which shows the access roads the details
of the hard standing would be
conditioned
would as would the levels be on site but
we do have a cross-section
showing these the properties of mount
pleasant
the red line shows existing ground level
and you can see how
they're proposing to change the levels
um and also provide this
buffer of wildlife corridor slash
green space alongside between the
through the statics and the dwellings on
mount pleasant
this is the uh cross-section running the
other way you can see how the site
actually slopes
um from mount pleasant um towards the
north and
also from west to east
showing the wider site layout
and this is the um a bit of a
run-through of the site this is the
access in
and the you can see the existing the
rear of the existing properties along
mount pleasant road
some of the existing statics on site and
these are
these are camping pods which have been
erected on the adjacent site
they're referred to as timber tents
they're temporary structures
this is the location's proposed
relocated play area
um but this site does have a separate
consent order in place from 2014
for um for touring caravans
if we just run through the site itself
you can see that this is the play area
to be removed you can see the
the rear of the dwelling from mount
pleasant there
you can see there the change in levels
across the site
and the existing access road
that's within the
so there we have the uh the hedgerows
along the east and western boundaries
and there's an area scrub along the
southern boundary
with the dwellings you can see the
difference in levels there
you can see the holiday pods on the
adjacent site and also the
separate holiday park
on the top of the hill this is the
existing golden sands
peppermint park site here
at the moment the land is used for
recreation purposes
and obviously the play area
this is the existing hedge row along the
eastern boundary
and you can see these are the the
adjacent neighbouring
holiday park
that's the player which is to be
relocated
so the officer recommendation remains uh
set out
in the report the permission be granted
subject to no objection being received
from natural england on or before the
25th of january in relation to the
appropriate assessment
and the applicant entering into a
section 106 agreement to secure a
habitat regulations assessment
contribution
in accordance with the joint approach
for the xs3 sba and ramsar sites and the
dollish warrant sac
and the conditions are set out in the
office report thank you chair
thank you okay if we could return right
okay i'll ask the other objective to
speak first and then i'll read out
the one that's been submitted for to be
read out so
it's kathy phillips please i could um
ask you to put your microphone on
good morning morning so you will have
five up to five minutes
from uh when you start speaking okay up
to you
thank you um this is a collective
objection
um points raised on behalf of the
residents for mount pleasant road
dawlish
the following points a reference to the
national planning policy framework and
cross-reference with the local planning
policy
these include s1 sustainable development
criteria s2 quality development
s5 infrastructure s7 carbon emission
targets
s9 sustainable transport s 11 pollution
s12 tourism s17 dualish s22 countryside
en 3 carbon reduction plans em4
flood risk en-6 air quality en 8
biodiversity protection enhancement
en9 important habitats and features
en-10
european wildlife sites en 11 legally
protected and priority species
en 12 woodland we11 green infrastructure
we 13 protection of recreational land
and the first heading is visual impact
first point dawlish warren in the
proposed field can be
seen from holden next smith and all the
points up the estuary
point two dallas warren is filled with
holiday parks caravans and mobile homes
which is an eyesore with no
consideration for local residents
with an already existing overpopulation
of the area and the third point over
development leads to overpopulated areas
local amenities and green space is
already limited for the existing
population in dualish war and dawlish
for such future developments to
accommodate extra provisions
including accessed health resources
local shopping space and recreational
areas for individuals to undertake
activity the next heading is
infrastructure
excess traffic and access to highways
first point currently has a 20 mile per
hour speed limit in place and not
30 mile per hour as noted in the
highways report
second point access to is limited to
dualis run for excess development with
roads being congested with holiday
makers roads being used to transport
heavy vehicles
caravans camper vans and mobile homes
damaging road surfaces and hedges
including weak lane and access through
cockwood which is narrow and safe for
pedestrian use
and the next point more individuals to
the area mean more transport and
therefore will increase pollution and
carbon emissions
and the next point current transport
infrastructure already unable to cope
increase not only by dawlish warren but
other developments in the locality and
the next heading is risk of flooding and
appropriate use of sewage and drainage
systems
first point already major surface water
flooding with inadequate drainage
systems in place
uh the second point there is a coastal
management plan in place to try and
attempt to cope with the existing
problem of flooding in the area
third point the smell of sewerage is
prevalent within duelish one without
adding to
current poor management of systems and
the fourth
water pressure is reduced especially in
the summer and the last point in that
heading following the initial
application in 2018 testing have been
undertaken in the summer at the highest
points of the field which has a natural
decline
and the next heading is ecology the
warren is key part of the excess street
ramsey site it is a national nature
reserve sack and site of special
scientific interest
and why while there is financial
contribution to the rspb
to ensure protection of surrounding
wildfowl and birds it's a great pity to
lose the limited green space available
where many types of birds roost and
frequent the third point fauna are
present in the field including bats and
badger
and the next point additional pollution
and lack of green space force
individuals to use the beach due to lack
of green space and dawlish raw and the
field is currently used for recreational
use by an already existing park area
which is well used for dog walkers to
exercise their dogs
the next point important should be given
to the current overall management of the
site the park does not maintain the
already existing maintenance within the
park
this is apparent in the field and the
close proximity areas to the field
including dumping of their rubbish
next point an increase in light and
noise pollution will also impact and be
problematic to permanent residents in
the fauna
and next point concern for the breaching
of undeveloped coasts
next point littering by individuals in
general lack of respect for the
environment in the field and local areas
current and ongoing issue
and it is an event inevitable that this
will create further issue
the last point lack of respect
inappropriate management and law abiding
um first point an authorised road
closure for a week laying for two
consecutive days without permission from
the devon highways department therefore
unlawfully blocking access to the
queen's highway
this was investigated by devon's highway
in november 2020
and the next point very recent
development of 15 camper pods in the
adjacent field where the proposed play
part should have been allocated and
already used the tent and camper vans
annually
um in the summer um in 2020
yeah that's time can you finish a
sentence please
um the air ambulance was called and had
difficulty landing in the field due to
lack of space
due to proximity of camp attempts to
land safely in a timely manner
and has remained consistently open
during the lockdown period
and permanent residence has been even
more evident as a result of ongoing
restrictions in the past 10 months
thank you and the negativity okay that's
it thank you five minutes is up
okay the um the other objection
comes from residents again mount prison
road residents they've asked for this to
be read out at the meeting so i'll
read it out thank you for this
opportunity to raise our concerns about
the proposed change of use
from greenfield stroke seasonal camping
to the sighting of 42
static caravans with associated roads
lighting and infrastructure
point one we consider this to be over
development
two dawlish warren already has over two
thousand static
caravans this proposal will potentially
add nearly 13 000 further visitors
a year 42 times 6 times 50
wishing to access the beach and
especially the nature reserve
as at high tide and either side of high
tide
there is no beach until beyond ruin
three
there is no direct access to the country
park where dogs are allowed
point three this over development
directly impacts on the adjacent special
protected area
and ramsar site an area of international
importance for wildlife
and the site of special scientific
interests triple ssi
which is less than 500 meters away and
as such
is subject to special wildlife
considerations
above and beyond a fiscal settlement per
unit
in mitigation which in reality
in no way mitigates the loss of habitat
point four the area forms a green
flight path from the conservation area
to open countryside and holden forestry
land
to the west and is home to badgers bats
foxes and wildflower contrary to the
submitted ecological report
0.5 present internet water pressure
and sewage problems encountered in the
summer will be exacerbated
six the application contravenes the tdc
local plan policy s 17 protection
wildlife sites we8 significant
dominant effect on mount pleasant road
properties
milling way shutterton lane the estuary
looking
south hexmuth and limstone
we11 green infrastructure
sections a b c e f g
and h e n 2 a
landscape protection sections a b c and
d
e n 4 flood risk critical drainage area
soak away testing was carried out
between october the 4th
and 8th 2018 following a sustained
dry and hot period with lower than
average rainfall creating a drier field
subsoil
and skewing results point seven
the application contravenes the national
planning policy framework
paragraph 117 preservation of habitats
and ecological networks point eight
the application contravenes the uh
conservation of habitats and species
regulation twenty seventeen
nine page four of the applicant's
planning statement
states a 30 meter separation stroke
buffer distance from mount pleasant road
gardens
however only 20 meters is detailed in
the planning committee report
approval condition 6. why is this
the 30 meter distance should be
reinstated
point 10 as residents we appreciate we
own property in a holiday area
and because of this tolerate anti-social
behavior
litter in our gardens noise music bad
language
haphazard road and grass parking without
this additional holiday accommodation
directly adjoining our properties so
that
was from other objectors
i could move on now please to
the supporter in batter and
you have up to 10 minutes
good morning chairman members the
national planning policy framework makes
it clear
that proposed development that accords
with an up-to-date local plan
should be approved unless other material
considerations
indicate otherwise you will have seen
from your committee report that this
development
is in accordance with your adopted local
plan
therefore the only matter to your
consideration is whether there are any
other material considerations
or of such significance that cannot be
adequately mitigated
my client has liaised over the last two
and a half years positively
with the various consorties and there
are no statutory objections to this
proposal
foul and surface water drainage which i
know over
best part of 40 years dealing with this
area has been
a consider a serious concern and has
been considered in some detail
based on the drainage schemes agreed in
relation to previous planning
permissions on this site
uh the foul drainage design ensures
control flows into the local mains
in common with the remainder of the
holiday park so that there's no
surcharging
surface water runoff is also balanced
through discharge to ground and then via
systems of swales and ponds
to ensure that flows are properly
attenuated in accordance with current
suds
practice these measures which have been
incorporated
throughout the existing park and the
adjoining golden sands park
properly manage foul and surface water
flows to avoid flooding
and surcharging of drains some members
may recall
the substantial contribution made by the
applicant concerning the shutterstone
brook
improvement works some years ago which
have materially improved flood risk
within doris warren as a whole
more importantly the lead local flood
authority has no objections
on the matter of ecology the submitted
ecological appraisal did not identify
any significant floor or fauna habitats
within and adjoining this largely open
grass field
nevertheless appropriate ecological
improvement measures
have been proposed perhaps the boundary
hedges are to be retained and added to
through buffer planting
scheme which will also help biodiversity
and allow
movement through the area there are no
arboric cultural and just to be clear
we also have a a a co-terminus
planning application on the golden sand
site which seeks to remove some of the
old chalet rose
and replace them with caravans there was
some concern over bats which was
confused
with this application as well yes bats
use the area i'm sure
uh as a flight route but that won't be
hindered by this scheme
uh and in fact so bat surveys have shown
that uh there are no
local roosts of concern
the applicant is perfectly content to
make the necessary habitat mitigation
contribution
they've done this in the past and up to
date have contributed over 35 000 pounds
to this scheme in relation to other
cases
although this is an extension to an
existing developed site
it's in a location that is
self-contained in the landscape
it adjoins an area to the east that was
previously approved touring caravans
and as you will have seen from the
photographs is actually overlooked
itself by
other other holiday parks care has been
taken in the submitted layout to ensure
the development is separate from
and appropriately buffered with the
adjoining properties
on mount pleasant road the roofs of the
upper level of holiday lodges
closest to these properties are set well
below the vision lines
of the north facing rooms as illustrated
on the on the cross section that you saw
your landscape officer acknowledges that
the development will have no impact on
the wider area holiday parks
are an important part of rural business
and this
should be supported issues surrounding
brexit and more recently the
restrictions on holiday opportunities
due to covid
have yet again focused attention on the
home holiday market
which is after all the raison d'etre of
doris warren in many ways
based upon evidence from national
research undertaken in 2019 the park
as currently developed contributes some
37 million pounds
every year into the local economy the
proposed development alone will add a
further
three and a half million pounds per
annum into the local economy through
direct and indirect revenue
contributions
this is part of a multi-pound upgrading
of this holiday park and its adjoining
park as part of a wider package
throughout my clients
portfolio the park relies upon a wide
variety of local businesses
and creates over 80 employment
opportunities for local people
in summary this proposal is in
accordance with your adopted local plan
policy
the report before you indicates there
are no planning objections to this
proposal
that could not or have not been
adequately mitigated by our discussions
as such there are no other material
considerations that impact
upon the presumption in favor of
granting planning permission and i
therefore ask
that you support your officer's
recommendation for approval accordingly
thank you thank you okay
um i
can just advise members that after we've
dealt with this
application then i will be having a
comfort break for members
so that in case you're wondering if
you'd remind me please at the end of
this one i'm looking
somebody's nodding okay um right the
the board members for this i'll invite
first then i see i've got another
speaker i know uh councillor wrigley is
asked to come in and speak and indeed it
was he
who asked for this one to go to
committee so i'll turn to councillor
wrigley first place
thank you chairman thank you for
allowing me to to to speak
uh we've heard a very aptly put from the
residents
many of their objections we've heard
some positive statements from
from the applicant here first of all i
would like to remind you that this isn't
a green field becoming caravan so this
isn't creating a business opportunity
this is changing one form of
accommodation to another
up until now this has been used in the
summer
for tents and uh people camping out in
the field so it is already
in use as business so it will not be
increasing
um the business uh the people coming
as much as one might imagine but what it
will do is change the nature of it
can i firstly ask in the conditions
all of the other holiday camp uh
permanent caravan
conditions ask for a register to be
maintained
that is missing from the condition uh
four
so condition four i would like to ask to
have the standard clause
that the uh of the operator maintains a
register that is available for team
bridge
to examine which every other park has
i know we don't always look at those and
we should be looking at those and i will
continue my campaign to have us
actually call in those registers for all
the camps i know before lockdown in
march we were starting to take action
over in livermore because people were
living in the caravans
now we have seen that significantly
during the last 10 months down at
dawlish warren
i have had phone calls from people
living in the caravan saying
please could we waive the conditions so
they could stay there through the
pandemic because they had nowhere else
to go
this is a scourge of the area that we
have to cram clamp down on
these these caravans are fine for
holidays
they are not fine for a permanent
accommodation and they are often being
used for that
and we need to prevent that why is that
important
well it means that we don't know where
vulnerable
adults are so for example in this time
of trying to bring people
to vaccination for kovid we don't have
an accurate
record of where they are living the
doctors do not know where they are
they're not on the local roles for
gaining the uh um
funding for the doctors let alone all
council services
and everything else
i brought this before this committee for
three
three main reasons i believe this to be
over development i believe
42 caravans in the site to be too many
but more importantly i believe the
impact on the ecology
and the flooding has been underrated
we've heard about the ecology report the
report that was filed with this
application
which has been in progress for what
nearly three years now
so there's no excuse for it not being
finished the report covered
largely lots of other areas within the
park
it was a very half-hearted attempt to
look at what ecology
there is going on within this field and
the local residents have reported to me
many sightings of badges
and owls and lots of birds and lots of
other things
none of which have been accounted for in
the ecology report
so i'd submit that ecology report is
insufficient and has been poorly done
and is largely as it states a desk
exercise
with a one day visit that actually
focused on the
newts and the ponds which is entirely
unrelated to this my biggest concern
is on drainage it was stated
by the uh um residents that this is a
critical drainage area and it
is this is an area that is classed by
the environment agency as a critical
drainage area that brings with it
higher standards required for any
development
in terms of runoff on the fields i don't
see that that has been mentioned
anywhere in the communications with the
flood consultant at devon and nor do i
see
a finished plan it worries me that after
three years
they haven't finished the plan for how
they're going to deal with the drainage
we know this area is subject to flooding
the
more long-standing members of you might
remember in 2000
we had next door hazelwood park or or
beechwood park is the residential part
of it is called
evacuated by helicopter because it was
flooded up to five foot deep
and people couldn't get out these are
that is a
an actual residential area where people
have permission to live there all year
round so we have many more people we
don't know how many people are going to
be there
if you look at where this site is we saw
the gradients
this leads directly down i even saw one
very worrying statement in the drainage
documents
that said they were going to pump their
excess water
into hazelwood park that doesn't seem
like a good idea when that area
is actually under sea water level it's
under under
under high tide level the right
that would be part of the mud flats if
the railway wasn't there in front of it
if you look at the maps you can see
that that is naturally part of the mud
flat flats part of the shore
the local residents there will show you
proudly the wall along dallas warren
road
which used to be the sea wall before the
um
railway was built not only
is the flooding aspect concerning for
surface water but the sewerage aspect is
concerning as well
i've spent the last seven years
working with southwest water trying to
get them to upgrade the sewerage there
are
serious issues in that part of dulish
and this is about 500 meters away from
the major
sewage processing plant
which is just on the top of the hill
opposite um
at um the name's gone out of my head
which is constantly smelling
over the summer we are working hard to
get uh southwest water to acknowledge
that it has a problem but it has a
problem putting an extra load on that
in this area is not advisable and not
going to help the situation at all
so given all of the issues
given that it is already a camping area
they might say well they'll move it
somewhere else more convenient well if
it was somewhere else more convenient
they'd already be having camping
holidays there so this is over
development 42 caravans is
too many i would urge that this be
reconsidered
a smaller scheme might well be
acceptable but this is over development
and this will make the local residents
misery life's misery
and by the way the pictures that were
shown of the overlooking holiday park
is in fact another small residential
area there are a dozen
uh um a dozen uh um
caravans up there that are permanent
residential you know cliff park
which is hidden behind the blue water
park but that's those are the pictures
we actually saw
so that's not holiday makers that's the
more vulnerable residents up there
please vote for addition adding the
condition
if you're going to pass this but i would
urge you to actually put this back for
reconsideration
to come back with a smaller site which
would be more appropriate
thank you thank you right um
counselor goodman bradbury you're also
award member so would you like to say a
few words
yes i would but i kind of think that an
awful lot of what i would like to cover
has been spoken so i'm not going to take
too much time of of members from that
point of view
um i i share a lot of the
um considerations and opinions of some
of the items that have been said
um i understand the business case of
course
for business for uh golden sands and i
take the points
and the the addition to the economy but
i do share the concerns of the residents
with the ecological report the drainage
the sewage
um but the size of the um the site
and the amount of caravans that are
looking to put into it
i do also concern myself with the
holiday makers and the quality of the
holiday that they're going to have
there's too many they seem to be packed
in
and with all the other concerns with
sewage with water drainage
i do feel this is over development and i
ask members to consider that fact
when they do look to to vote for
this um site i'm not going to take
any other time up we've already had a
lot of speaking from that point of view
but i would urge you to to consider and
and vote against this item
thank you thank you councillor mcgregor
thank you chair i do apologize about the
uh
unmuting i i poured some red wine on my
laptop and it didn't like it
um the um there are a number of things
that that kind of leap out and
and counselor goodman bradbury has
highlighted one and the word i would use
is
shoehorned um in respect of the number
of
of um units to go into that particular
site but
the biggest concern for me um
particularly
as as portfolio holder for the uh air
sport leisure and culture site
is the fact that we haven't actually
asked the rangers for
for an opinion either dualish warren
itself
is um significantly damaged
by the current visitor levels that we
receive
uh increasing that um through a
a the shoe horning in of all these uh
these
these units would potentially increase
the the uh
the erosion the damage to the
environment
um and and i think that the sheer
footfall the waste
the the additional thing would put an
unfair burden and
you know with the best will in the world
you know s 106 contributions only
mitigate they don't actually address the
problem
um the other aspect and another hugely
concerning one
is that the drainage side of it uh
specifically the comment from
our own officer the site falls within
all this critical
drainage area as defined by the
environment agency which means that
catchment
needs to be prevented uh protected sorry
from development measures that's quite a
significant statement
where we have already acknowledged that
there are difficulties
with drainage and that there are
difficulties with sewage
and processing etc within the area
significantly increasing development is
just going to add to that problem
and it is actually going to be contrary
to the dullish critical
uh drainage area protection and
specifically um you know coming back to
conditions and this this always does
concern me
is that conditions are seen as after the
fact
i would i would have expected having
received the report from the drainage
officer
where he notes um i can advise the
applicant has not provided any
information in relation to disposal of
surface water
the site will introduce additional
impermeable areas
compared to the existing situation the
assumption of infiltration data should
be clarified
with appropriate testing and appropriate
designs of any uh proposed infiltration
devices
and permeable surfaces one would expect
that
to be in place before the application
comes for consideration
rather than having it as a condition
after approval
or or refusal has been granted
this is key and critical information
that is needed
to make proper decisions
and i i on that basis my my
recommendation would be to refuse and i
move that
thank you is that seconded
yeah councillor parker has put his hand
up
um okay i'll ask um anna to come back
but i do have a question myself
um i share the concerns expressed about
drainage and sewage issues which
may not be as fully answered in in what
i've read
having heard the representations but the
question i have relates to the
um the habitat regulation contribution
now we've got the calculation of the
contribution
um on the basis of the number of units
and the number of people that would
occupy them
as would be similarly the case if it was
new dwellings and we're all familiar
with that
um the issue that's come up today that
i have to sort of stop and reflect on is
the fact that whilst
that contribution is what you would
normally expect
to mitigate from an area close to the
warren
the the argument about this green area
being lost
for recreational use for dog walking
will be i know there'll be some uh
walking areas around the periphery of it
um i i would myself consider that that
actually increases the pressure
on the area of the um
x estuary um because of people not
having the opportunities to work
walk around within the site as they
previously would
so i i'd like an answer to that question
as well because to my mind
it means that what's currently being
asked for is
is not a sufficient amount
given that we've created additional
recreational
space elsewhere within the vicinity
but here we are losing an area of
currently
uh open recreational land
um and can i also ask for a response on
the
point that council wrigley made under
item four on the
um conditions that are propos that are
suggested
um relating to whether a register uh
would be kept and if that would be added
in
so can i ask anna to respond to those
issues of the
the drainage sewage and the
contributions
and so on
yes chair um in terms of the critical
drainage area
um there's been a lot of discussions
between the applicant and seven county
councils the lead local flood authority
um and subject to the condition they
propose
that they have no objection to the
application
um so that would that would be a
pre-commencement condition which the
applicants have agreed to
which would mean they'd need to address
all of those points before
the development commences on the site in
terms of
the um the payment for the accessory
dornish warren
the joint habitat contribution the
um the payment is calculated um
most holiday units have a discount over
the
full residential amount but because of
the proximity
there is a multiplier added to this site
which
actually brings it back up to what we'd
expect for full-time residential use
so that that has been addressed within
the joint contribution which is our
established
way of mitigating that impact
the at the moment the space has a play
area on which would be relocated
in terms of the ad hoc use of that space
for walking of dogs
um there's no planning protection for
that
i mean we would want to see the play
space relocated
um but obviously you said that they used
the site for
um tents and camping and everything else
so um
it is within the park itself and
um it wouldn't in office's opinion
justify refusal
for the loss of that space
sewage uh in terms of sewage
um there's uh they will need obviously
they need to relate with southwest water
in terms of the connection for that
um and if there are existing issues
um that would largely be a matter for
southwest water to
to resolve um in terms of of those
of those existing issues um or any
existing issues that exist
so again um officer opinion is that that
wouldn't justify
a refusal of planning permission for the
current proposal
thank you councilman oh and sorry i'm
sorry
the proposed register for occupants um
yes that is uh that can be included with
the proposed condition for
um as as has been the case for
other parks um and other applications of
this nature
so yes that would um that could be
included as part of that condition
thank you council not all
i thank you just very briefly i'd just
like us all to note
that dawlishtown council uh resolved
unanimously
recommending refusal of this application
for
many reasons as set out by yourself by
councillor wrigley
and others i just think that's worth
noting thank you chad
thank you um i think the issue we need
to
address though is the sort of robust
reasons for refusal that we need to
be able to come up with um i think it
was
was it council mcgregor who moved
refusal um
and um
can we can we consider what the reasons
might be and then i'll ask the officer
to
um give some uh response to that
because we need to to have some um
specific reasons
um you know despite the the lead um
flood
um element i i believe that uh our own
flood risk manager um you know the the
drainage and coastal manager
highlights the the issue as
um this is a a critical drainage area
and needs protected from development
and i think that is contrary to the idea
of protecting from development
and i think it exceeds the the current
level
particularly in light of the fact that
there is no identified
plan to mitigate for drainage
on site yeah i think can i just
stop you on that one the the problem
would be
whether this is normally what the
government would be happy
to be addressed by a condition and of
course it's condition
five that is the condition there so i
think
um we need to have some guidance on
whether we're able to use that as a
reason for refusal or whether
the condition that would enable it to
to be overridden um i don't know whether
roz wanted to
to comment on on that sort of general
way of conditions used thank you chair
and i think it's it's useful to read the
the whole of the response that we we've
had from
um uh the lead local flood authority
which and the conditions that they've
recommended are really clear that
they're not suggesting that we don't
know what's going to happen with the
drainage here
there's a strategy in place but what
they're requesting through their
conditions is is some additional
technical details that would
um it's fairly normal that scheme design
reaches a certain level of detail and a
certain point
um up until the point where planning
permission is granted for a scheme or a
development and then after that the
technical
work continues to get um further uh
analysis or further connections and
specific site locations
known so that the details are understood
before the development is implemented
and that's what's happened in this case
so we've had a surface water drainage
strategy submitted and there's been
a lot of significant tuning and throwing
between the various technical experts
and
on my reading of the consultation
responses that we've got including that
from richard rainbow
our in-house engineer there would be no
technical support from
either from county or from richard
for refusal of this application on uh
drainage grounds that doesn't mean that
you can't refuse it on jaina's ground
uh obviously it just means you need to
be really clear and think about whether
or not um
there are any technical reasons um for
that refusal
to be taken forward because if without
that technical support and backup
um from either our in-house uh expertise
or from
devon county council then clearly there
would be a serious risk of that being
considered as an unreasonable reason for
refusal
thank you okay council mcgregor do you
want to carry on with the other reasons
as well please
um over well just to return to that that
one particular point
i think it's worth noting that
councillor wrigley's input
um in terms of part of the the response
that was given
um is that um they were going to
uh pump the water from the site but into
a low
low level uh below high tide area which
would again
present us with a potential further risk
of
flooding and it is in the zone two
flooding area
um so from that perspective i think
drainage is still a concern
um i know the um business plan
planning manager's um position on that
but i think that is still a concern
i think also over development of the
site um
bearing in mind that there is a
previously existing holiday destination
and the use of that field
currently exists for camping i think
this is nova development and i think
there are far too many units
being shoehorned into the site and it is
uh quite considerable over development
bearing in mind
the pressures on drainage and water
outfall
and surface water okay thank you so
those are the reasons for refusal that
you would
um be putting forward the drainage and
the over development
yeah okay councilman bradford
i'm i'm very concerned about all of the
wildlife
um mitigations only reducing the
severity of
something that's already bad and
we've lost 50 percent of our wildlife
we've declared
an environmental emergency and i don't
think we should be
killing off anything else um also
practically the rangers as
councilman councillor mcgregor mentioned
they
they are overstretched now they've got
so much to look after and i think that's
a big consideration
thank you thank you
okay nobody else has indicated they wish
to speak
so i will therefore
take the motion that's before us that's
the
motions for refusal for the two main
reasons being drainage
and over development um so
nobody else is saying anything we'll
have the vote on that now please
so can i ask chris to go can you read me
please mike sorry the the motion before
you
is for refusal uh the reasons being as
outlined by council mcgregor that's
drainage
and over development thank you okay so
it's
for refusal so if you wish to refuse you
will vote for
obviously if you are against refusing
your vote against
thank you okay chris can you go through
please
yep thank you chair councillor bradford
for
councillor bulovant against
councillor clarence against
also cole clough paul councillor cox
for councillor hayes
councillor hook against
cancer jeffrey how's the
um kurzweil
try to cancel your muted
sorry against
council mcgregor or council nutley
or council natto or
how's the parker four
councillor patch what how's the goodman
bradbury
and councillor haynes against
that's 11.5 chair yes that's how i have
it so that
is carried so that application has been
refused for the reasons that have been
outlined
okay as i indicated earlier i think we
need
a comfort break so um i would ask
um that we reconvene
let's i'll make it about eight minutes
seven minutes two
should we say five past twelve and we'll
have to take the
um register again um roll call
to log everyone back in um chris can you
deal with the situation if members could
turn themselves to mute and turn off
their cameras
and then see you back here at five past
twelve
chris i'll make it five past ever
yes gerald turn this off now
this is a heavy breather
chairman i'm sorry but um i am here
but it it doesn't look as though i am
yeah i can see you on the list
uh avril yeah i am here but um
i don't know why but it the camera's not
showing me on the
screen but i am here
yeah the camera the camera isn't shown
and switched off
sorry about that i don't know what's
happened
yeah it's just the background you've got
a background on that yeah
it may be that um that's causing a
problem i know earlier
um phil seemed to be sort of fading into
his background and then came back out
again so i don't know whether those are
the issues
is it if you're able to look at
that right um
chris can you take the roll call please
thank you chair um counselor proud
president councillor bulovant
councillor clarence president
councillor colclough president
councillor cox prison councillor goodman
bradbury
present councillor haynes
councillor hayes
councillor hook
council jeffrey
councillor kurzweil
councilman mcgregor present also natalie
prison council
present councillor parker
present and counselor patch present
thank you chair thank you
or is he just not back it seems like
he's still got his camera off
he's just just reappeared okay so
council bullets present as well all
right so that's
that's done then chris is it yeah
thank you thank you all right if we move
on then we're on to
item e under under five that's
uh shellco house at dulish um
we have got um two
public speakers on this one uh so
if we could have them in and then i'll
ask garter to to start the presentation
so can we have the public speakers
admitted please
you
right i can see both supporter and
objector down on the
on the list there i think um if i could
ask them both please to
mute their microphones and then
um i'll ask arta to go through the
presentation
okay can see them both on the screen
right okay arthur can you go through the
presentation okay
can you go through the presentation here
yes
can you hear me okay sorry i didn't hear
that can you
hear me now yes i can hear whoever that
was
hello yeah
i'm just gonna share my screen
oh sorry chris can you just make me a
co-host
there you go thanks arthur hey thanks
okay
cheers
you just scroll up on that one
um so can everyone see that fine
yes yes
okay so this is an application for
formation of six new dwellings
um at shell cove house
um this is the site location so um
they'll be located um in the area
uh where former tennis court was
um the application's part of a larger
redevelopment as you can see uh within
the blue
line there is a major scheme approved in
2016 that involves
two new apartment buildings um and
cottages
um along the ultim mountain of road
so this is just an aerial photo
so you can see the proximity to the
cliff and
any arrangement of the dwellings um
neighboring
um the site will utilize uh the access
that comes that's consented
uh under the 2008
major application for their neighboring
development
um so this is a block plan uh members
might
uh be aware that there was a previous
consent on on this site in 2015
for same number of dwellings um however
this is a new application
um it's a complete change of design for
uh towards a kind of more contemporary
um terrace housing uh design uh the
layout
lights layout slightly changed we've got
introduction of carports
um to the front of the dwellings where
previously
um the the parking was um
located to the east of the site so the
buildings have been set back
to accommodate the car parts and uh
also with the car parts offer um
additional parking spaces i think it
is something from seven to 12 parking
spaces from
from the previous consent
so here are the elevations that's your
front elevation
um it's a 1.5
total height increase on on the previous
site uh this is including the um
lantern light above the staircase
but it's only not 0.9 meters increase in
height
um to the ax to the height of the main
main roof
so you can see on the western
side um the buildings are two-story so
these will be phase
facing the the neighboring properties
and the carports
and then on the eastern side
um the is proposed for the ground to be
excavated to accommodate a lower
lower ground floor which will come out
um
into the gardens as
seen on elevations
so these are just the kind of side
elevations so you can see that
the carport the existing boundary wall
which is being retained and this is
roughly where the entrance is going to
be
um and this is just the other side
of the uh of the dwellings
here you can see there's a section for
the site
uh which shows um relationship to bread
and the tom house and papillon which are
the closest
properties to the site so we've got a
rough
um separation distance between
um this house and the new development
of around 23 to 25 meters
and here are just some pictures from
from the site so this is
looking into the site from um roughly
where the access is going to be
so this is the north east corner
we can see the relationship of the the
neighboring properties from uh breton
house slightly set above
looking over the site and papillon which
is
located behind the wall yeah
and this is from the north western
corner
along this wall is where they're um
where the car parts will be located uh
we can't see bradley
house in this picture there but is is
kind of roughly located somewhere behind
that vegetation there
so with this one there is a
recommendation for approval with
with a range of um conditions covering
the cliff stability in conjunction
working with
network rail and a section 106
contribution
for affordable housing
all right thank you right thank you
i've got a neck on your um and data
thank you um right we've got the public
speakers first of all the objective
please let's go
so if i could ask you have um it's a
full application so it's three minutes
each on that and when you start
thank you um so the huge risk with the
cliff
on this site hasn't been adequately
considered uh the only submission is the
2013 pegasus report and this is for a
different proposal with no detailed
assessment
and it fails to document multiple
failures on the site
it is only based on visual assessment
and generic engineering and i consulted
a geotechnical engineer to review the
report
and he told me this was inadequate to
determine risk there is no detailed
scientific investigation of risk from
the cliff
or the development's impact upon this
new cliff evidence was not considered in
the previous application
and has not been given adequate
consideration for this application
this was dismissed on the basis of
networkrail's lack of comment yet on the
previous application they stated
a network rail has serious concerns this
proposal if permitted could destabilize
the cliff
as the area concerned has a high profile
of cliff failures
and nothing has changed direct quotes
from this evidence refer to
tension cracks very weak poor condition
of the rock
significant risk of large scale slope
failure poor geotechnical
characteristics failure of up to 2500
tons of material
the geology of the cliffs is such that
further falls remain likely
a large scale slate failure of the upper
section is a likely event
extremely weathered in the upper third
of the cliffs and
extremely weak and weathered ground
conditions this is the most detailed
information we have
we know the cliffs are at risk we know
from local studies that
future more severe weather events will
place greater risk but we don't know
what the cumulative impact of building
close to the cliff edge will be
whereas the geotechnical document which
says building a development close to the
cliff
with a history of failures is okay
where's the guarantee that no one will
lose multiple meters of their property
to the cliff in the future
and last year 50 meters to the east of
the site this happened
we do not know when or toward extent but
at some point the cliff will have a
failure
and at what point is this acceptable
someone could buy a house and lose part
of their garden or worse in the future
and are you signing this off and saying
that that's not going to happen
or are you satisfied that as it might
happen in five to ten years or more that
makes it okay
i've spent 12 years working for a major
international engineering consultancy
and if that information came to light on
a project it would not only be properly
assessed but we would be looking
uh likely to be looking at sites
elsewhere
and the key immunity is the coastal
aspect we can argue about view versus
immunity but it is the fact that this is
the main enjoyable feature and reason
for sufficient properties here
the developer themselves was advertising
on this basis and the development will
destroy this for neighboring properties
with no compromise
the development is detrimental to the
character of the area too high density
for the small site and too imposing
it is 1.5 meters higher 25 percent uh
greater in build superior uses more
asphalt and less green landscaping than
the previous proposal
the north facing windows are four times
larger this is an invasive privacy
regardless of arguments around angle of
view
it should be also be considered
alongside the cumulative impact of the
developer's proposal for large flats on
the adjacent plot this is over
development in a scenic setting
and whilst due to the cliff it is
ludicrous to build here there is
compromise to lessen the impact a one or
two
story development maintaining a cut away
ground floor limits its imposing nature
that's time okay finish your sentence
please
break up the number of properties
provide more open green space reduce
asphalt and reduce the north facing
window size
thank you okay um
can i ask now the um supporter please
to uh unmute and then you'll be three
minutes from when you start
see if i can see you've unmuted okay so
start when you when you're ready good
afternoon
my name is regina nelson i'm a chartered
town planner an agent for the
application representing poppy
developments
residential development on this site is
acceptable as it
is within the settlement limits of
dualish the application site
also already benefits full planning
permission six houses
the consideration today is therefore
essentially a revised proposal
for the same number of homes we believe
the current proposal is an improvement
compared to the scheme with planning
permission
in terms of residential immunity the
proposal has been designed sensitively
to the three existing surrounding
dwellings
bradenton house shrimp lodge and
papillon it is important to be aware
that this proposal locates the six new
homes
further away from bradenton house and
shrimp lodge than the site's existing
planning permission
as the new homes are located 14 meters
away from the boundary
whereas the permitted scheme located the
houses adjacent to the boundary
separation distances between bradenton
house and shrimp lodge and the proposal
are therefore increased over the
separation distances in the permitted
scheme
a distance between the proposal and the
existing redemption house of over 23
meters is achieved
which is in its test that the suggested
20 meters are set out in the design
guide
in respect of shrimp lodge this is
increased to over 40 meters
given these measurements it is
considered that no detrimental impact
the outlook of neighbouring properties
is caused also as prudentin house is
elevated
and orientated to the northeast rather
than being parallel to the proposed
this helps minimize direct overlooking
for papillon
this property is 10 meters from the
proposal's northeast elevation
a boundary wall separates the two
properties and the height of the
proposed is similar
the only opening that will overlook
papillon will have obscure glazing to
prevent any potential minor overlooking
in respect of cliff stability and the
objecting party's concerns
network rail has been consulted multiple
times for this current application
and for the previous planning permission
for this application they have been
consulted twice
most recently in december last year
their response time and time again
has confirmed that there is no objection
and that there are no additional
comments debate from their initial
response
and that the conditions proposed are
sufficient to facilitate the development
there are no technical objections
relating to cliffstability
from network rail or any other
professional body
appropriate monitoring of the cliff
during the construction
and the life of development will be
enforced by a condition
to conclude i'd like to politely remind
members that view is not considered to
be a planning consideration
regards should only be given to outlook
when weighing up the planning balance
and given the comfortable separation
distances
which which are in excess of guidance it
is considered that there is not a
detrimental impact
to the outlook of the neighbouring
properties there are not any technical
objections to the proposal there is also
the contribution of 237
and 608 pounds for off-site affordable
housing
which has been agreed i politely ask
that in accordance with your office's
direct
recommendation you will vote to approve
this application
thank you for listening thank you
okay um we don't have any ward members
present
um this item was requested to go to
committee buyer it was the town council
i do have question myself which relates
i mean
to me the only issue that um raised any
concern
was the cliff stability
which obviously was raised by the first
public speaker but was also addressed
just now by the um the agent for the
applicant
um i'm having listened to that i would
be content if our officer could confirm
that obviously network
rail are themselves happy with what's
proposed
and there is the condition number 18
which is obviously for ongoing
monitoring
of the stability of the cliff because
we're talking here about a cliff
that is um down to the railway not down
to the sea
but we know of issues of cliff
instability
further back up down the line in the
direction of timbus which
obviously have caused problems in the
past so
arthur can you just clarify the position
with network rail please
uh on the cliff stability yep thank you
chad
so um as the supporter said so we've
consulted
um network rail twice uh
on this uh originally um
they they came back with a range of
conditions and then
um obviously bearing in mind some of the
objections that came in mind
bringing some material forward i um
gone to network rail pointing out um
those
those objections um to ensure that they
are happy with
with the the cliff issue on the site uh
they came back with no further comments
so
um the conditions um then
so there is a monitoring um cliff
um condition and there's also a range of
conditions in terms of the drainage to
ensure that any of those works don't um
don't affect their stability uh and also
construction management plans and
management plans to ensure that um
during construction uh that the cliff
is being monitored and is stable
all right thank you um i've got a couple
of people wish to speak
uh council government bradbury
thank you um although not the ward
member obviously a near neighbor
and i do recall at the town council
indulge the main objection
that was uh before us was the fact that
uh network rail had a real concerns
about the cliff
and wanted the um the positioning and
the size
of the three-story buildings as they
were in the past
um they basically put the main objection
to us um so hence the concerns
from the the town council
these concerns have been withdrawn in
this um at this time
and from that point of view i'm
reassured as well that there's a program
for monitoring the stability of the
cliff
of course it's in network rails interest
to do exactly that as
you rightly said mike the railway
literally does run at the bottom of
their garden from that point of view
i see the improvements that have been
made for the
nearby residents and the properties and
there were concerns about overlooking
but the the
separation of the actual buildings and
the carport does
does put more distance and i was
reassured to hear 23 to 25 meters
separation
with the properties from that point of
view i'm
i'm more comfortable with with this
this prospect and this
item and i would move that we
approve as set out thank you
seconded i'll second that
if um okay he's put me down to second
that one then please write
counselor hook um thank you chair
um yeah again we need to bear in mind
that this has got a plan in history and
a previous commission
on this site um i wanted to sort of
um raise another point now i'm
disappointed that
in the conditions there's no
consideration of how the residents that
live in these houses
will be encouraged to use sustainable
travel means
um we do have a policy in our local plan
um
s9 that refers to sustainable travel
considerations
one of those said that we should support
infrastructure for electric vehicles
and this is becoming standard now i
think in most commissions we give for
residential and other development
and it should be standard um especially
in this type of development where the
carports are
actually slightly distant from the
houses so um
if residents had electric cars in these
properties
it wouldn't be easy for them to charge
them
um so i mean it might be you know some
sort of condition that says
the they must be made ev ready even if
we're not actually putting in the
charging facilities at the moment
that if a person decides they would
would like
to charge an eb car they can just
quickly install the necessary um
facility to do that
so i'd like to ask for that to be added
and also of course um
cycles i'm not seeing anywhere there
that's um
suggesting where people might store a
cycle if they had one
and may i suggest that since the parking
provision is quite generous
that one of those carports could
actually um quite simply be a
cycle store with sort of lockable
compartments within it
um so i'm wondering whether that could
be
included as a condition other than that
i'm happy with what's proposed
okay i'll ask the officer to comment on
that i'm not sure about the cycling if
it
wasn't in the existing plan i know we've
talked about it for the plan moving
forward
but
implications of that so in terms of the
cycling
uh it might have not been clear from um
from the floor plans but the the car
parts uh
what they're also allowing is at the
back of the car pots there is
a storage compartment uh included for
the use of
of um of the occupiers of of the
individual dwellings so
um that will give the opportunities
to store um cycles or
or whatever whatever the uh the
occupants
choose choose to put um there but but
there is that possibility
and the vehicle charging question
uh if i can take that one i would expect
and anticipate that these car ports
would have some form of lighting in them
so i would it
i would have thought that that would be
a simple condition that we could attach
and i'd be happy and would support and
endorse
the inclusion of that that condition
okay thank you
right uh council mcgregor thank you
chair um
just a quick question in terms of the
swept path path analysis
that's been done for the site for waste
vehicles because they're coming
off the road into a small development
and then back out onto the road
what what are the measurements that have
been notified to the waste
team in terms of the the amount of space
for the vehicles to get through
and the amount of maneuvering room once
they're in there
also um so i don't know of the top of my
head
but um the swept path analysis was
actually requested by
our uh waste team and they've given
um the kind of standards uh dimensions
um which i uh then uh communicated
to the agent uh and then once i've
received the
sweat path analysis that went to our
waste team and they were happy
that um there's been kind of sufficient
simulation
uh for the size of the vehicles for them
to be happy
uh with that but i can uh come back to
you on the exact measurements
if you could because i've got for that
um
would be does it um does it also meet
the requirements of the building
regulations b5
which has a certain size with the
maneuvering
area for fire brigade vehicles which is
actually larger
than the vehicle requirements for the
wasting
well if it doesn't meet building
regulation requirements one presumes
that they wouldn't actually be able to
proceed with it and they'd have to come
back with any amendment i mean i don't
know whether
um um rose wants to comment on the sort
of overall
principle of that i i know council
mcgregor you're very mindful of a recent
one that we went to in timbuth which um
clearly was demonstrated to be the case
but this one i think as a sort of more
of a new build it's not
likely to have those problems and and
our own team have looked at it
uh ross did you want to comment on that
please i i just reiterate the point that
you've made their chair
um the access to the site has been
considered by our waste team and
considered acceptable and likewise by
devon county council
and we try not to get too involved as a
planning
team in in um whether or not things
would pass building regs but clearly
there's no point in us granting planning
permission for something that wouldn't
pass building reg so
we do our best to be mindful of these
things but um
we are also guided by government that we
shouldn't overlap with those regimes
in terms of access to the site the bins
the bin lorries won't be going into this
application site itself on the block
plan there is
a um a bin collection point so
the the vehicles won't be expected to
get into and maneuver within the site
itself they'll be accessing the overall
sites um coming to the bing collection
points and then going away
and there are bin storage facilities
shown on the site layout plan
um so that it's an easy move for the
residents to take their bins out to the
to the bin
collection point none of the distances
are very large um i appreciate that the
guidance in relation to
access and fire regulations uh has
changed and change continues to change
in response to um tragedies such as
grenfell and it is something that we all
need to be increasingly mindful of
but in this instance i certainly don't
see that there's any reason for refusal
connected to
whether or not the the fire appliances
would be able to get into this site or
not
thank you okay council patch
thank you chair um from the
images of the development it does it
like a very attractive development
i must say this type of development um i
was
drawn and my attention was drawn to the
points objector made regarding the
potential risk in terms of cliff
stability and
i might be asking for details that's not
readily to hand
but it does just strike me that um
particularly given that the changes in
weather patterns we're getting where
we're getting
lots of rain and i know we've got a lot
forecast this next couple of days but i
just wonder whether the
analysis of the structural risk to that
area in the cliff
does has that taken into account these
are increasing
sort of risk of heavy rainfall over
extended
um periods of time as i say i'm not sure
whether that information is available
but if it is it would be
interesting to know
how to review any detail on that
if i can comment generally yeah um if we
just consider
um and i know that it's not an
application that's before us now but
members are familiar with the work of
the southwest rail resilience
partnership
through the applications that we've had
before us in relation to
projects at marine parade and coast
guard colonnade
in daulish where the network rail
planning team is acutely aware
of the increasing storminess that we may
well be facing as a consequence of
climate change that we
anticipate facing as a consequence of
climate change so i do think that
network rail as a whole and their
their planning team and therefore their
consultation team um
as all professional planners are mindful
of
the um changing climate that we live in
uh whether it is set out specifically in
those terms within the relevant
documentation or not
is not something i can answer but what
we do have is a really clear
consultation response from network rail
that says that subject to the
application is the conditions that are
included in our recommendation
and some of the more technical ones we
also included as an appendix to this
report as well just because they are
um non-standard and and so to make sure
that we and you
understand what it is that is proposed
and there is no uh
objection from network rail um whether
it is explicit in the paperwork or not
about the the increased rainfall that
would be going into that um cliff
stability analysis or not i don't know
but
um i don't know whether arta has been
able to pull anything off up on that but
um in general terms i think we're all
comfortable
and that sufficient technical analysis
has been undertaken to date
yeah i concur with that i don't think
there's any any need for any more
from arter on that it's been answered
already um
okay so we've got the motion that was
proposed by councillor goodman bradbury
council government are you happy to
incorporate that one
uh additional thing which was the
vehicle charging
um that was uh suggested by councillor
hook and
agreed to by cancer eastman would you be
happy to
separate that absolutely yeah that's a
real positive step so of course
yeah and the second uh i would as well
so there's no one else indicated to
speak
so the motion then is approval
as set out with that one additional
point so
can i ask chris to go through you'll be
voting for
approval for against chris
thank you chair um councillor bradford
councillor bellevant councillor clarence
councillor colclough councillor cox
councillor cox four
councillor hayes four
councillor hook oh
councillor jeffrey yeah
councillor kurzweil councillor mcgregor
or councillor nutley or
council natal councillor parker
or cancer patch
councillor goodman bradbury
four and councillor haynes
yes you know this chair yep thank you
we've
all agreed thank you very much for that
right so if i could ask for the
uh two public speakers to be um
moved to the waiting room please
um and then
before we go on to the next item which
is
5f the tpo we have
a supporter well
we'll support an object our bigger
pardon an objector
in as much as objects into the tpo that
needs to be admitted
and i see that the objector is
with us
somewhere
sure i can see him with us now his
camera's on
right i i yeah i was looking i found i
found him on the participants list but
couldn't oh there we are yes i can i can
see
the objectives in the order now and also
council malone will be wishing to speak
on this one
so he's already there so if i could ask
mr sample we'll go through the
um offices offices presentation first
and then i'll invite you to speak so
could you
please uh mute your microphone in the
meantime
that's it thank you okay so um
it's um
to give the presentation please
okay thank you uh thank you chair
don't you share my screen can you see
that okay
yes okay thank you
uh so this uh report concerns the
confirmation or otherwise of these
districts of
team bridge 17a south road number two
tree preservation order
2020. the tree preservation order itself
protects the group of two monterey
pine trees that are located in the front
garden of 17a
south road the tree preservation order
was made on the
21st of july 2020
and the provisional protection will seat
on the 21st
of january 2021 if it's not
confirmed the uh an original tree
preservation order
was made on the 27th of uh january 2020
following um a conservation or
notification
informing the council that the african
wish to fell the two
trees the um owing to the cobia
restrictions at the time
the original tree preservation order
wasn't confirmed
so the tree preservation order we're
discussing today was made
to rebate it and to ensure the
continuing protection of the uh
of the trees the um
the trees are highly visible and
contribute to the visual amine to the
area
and the loss of the trees would be would
be detrimental to the wider conservation
area
collectively the trees have an
administrative rating of
16. the suitable benchmark for
inclusion within a tree preservation
order is generally guarded
as 15.
we've received one objection to the
making of the tree preservation order
and so if i summarize the objection uh
it's as follows
the original conservation area
notification did not attract any
objections from members of the public
the trees or sections of the trees may
fall or fail
and a large limb from a from a tree
fell in the recent past causing
significant damage
to the applicant's property in response
to the objections
uh once um it's noted that no objections
were received to the uh
original conservation and notification
um the stated previously the
tree is highly
and contribute to the visual immunity of
the area uh accordingly
was made the
the objection was accompanied by a
brief tree report that discussed the
condition of the trees
the tree report was then taken from a uh
from the ground
and no climbing inspection was
undertaken
the inspection suggested that there's an
area of decay approximately 20 meters
of one of the trees however without
climbing inspection it's impossible to
actually confirm the presence of the
decay
the extent of the decay or whether the
decay has any structural influence on
this on the trees uh
and i i couldn't notice any significant
areas of decay
so uh so i i consider that there's no
evidence that's being put forward that
the trees are liable to uh to fail
with regard to the uh the final uh
objection
the council is obviously very
sympathetic to the stress that is caused
by the failure of
another tree that isn't included within
this tree preservation order
um however as it wasn't included with
this tree preservation order
it doesn't appear particularly relevant
in considering whether this order should
be confirmed
thank you chair thank you
we could go back to the um
normal screen thank you okay right can i
invite then the objector which is mr
sample i believe um to speak
you've got three minutes so if you'd
like to unmute your microphone
and then you can speak to us
hello can you hear me yes okay okay
uh right so my friend thank you very
much okay so
um i'd like to talk about the free trees
obviously and objects
um the the main reason for this or
there's a couple of reasons
when the beast of the east came back on
the 2nd of march 2018
um as the uh officer said uh a large
monterey pine over a hundred and
probably about 110 120 foot crushed for
our house nearly killed the three of us
my wife my daughter um we
moved out obviously the house was
rebuilt these trees
that i'm referring to the two montreal
pines
are off consider
the age of these trees must be between
85 to 90 years
i understand that the average age for a
tree of this uh
elk is um 80 to 90 years and the the
height of it uh
ranges from 20 uh from 90 to 110
feet okay my main concern is that
they're both built on steep banks
and whereas they are very efficient from
the roadside if you look from the garden
side
should those trees fall or fail the full
range is something that i
wish you to consider considerably
because
the house is some 30 foot from those
trees
and the neighboring apartments
in church path are approximately 60 foot
away
so should these trees fail not only
could they cause
considerable damage and loss of life to
further people
it's something that is being overlooked
i feel
uh from the office's point of view now
if you also
look at the um the trees okay
from the from the garden you'll note
that there are two unions
in those trees and some of those unions
are arriving
against other trees which could which
would obviously cause them stress
okay and considerable could be
damaging high winds i'd also like to say
that
the visual immunity of south vote has
somewhat changed
over the last few years with
developments taking place
just up the road and potentially across
the neighbouring fields so
i don't think it's unreasonable for me
to ask
the council to reconsider my application
to
remove one tree have one tree pruned and
the beech tree that overhangs my
neighbor's property
needs pruning back because again growth
takes place
that's my case thank you thank you
right if i could um go to the world
member now i know council bradford has
declared an interest so she's not going
to speak on this
um but council malone has asked to speak
so
can i ask him please to speak now hi
can you hear me yes yeah brilliant um
yeah i'm not going to speak for the for
the changing enviro
environments of uh of these trees
because obviously
uh i and my party don't don't want those
environments to change but
having visited the property uh which i
think you need to to appreciate the
topography of the site
it is clear that the the house is very
much at the mercy of the trees above it
i mean it's not as if
you've got a house here and you've got a
tree x meters
distant from it uh these two monterey
pines as i understand they are
uh growing out of a precipitous slope
which itself begins one or two stories
above the base of the house below it
so as you stand on the pavement you know
you're at the same level or not far off
the top of the house
and you can easily surmise that if a
tree were to fail
and fall that distance onto the house it
would it would probably go
it would have to go down the slope
there's any way it can go and if it hit
the house it would go through it like
cheese wire
i i i i believe mr sample when he says
that uh
you know he he would not want to remove
a tree without any good reason
uh but i i don't think he should uh he
should have to
live his life in fear of it either i
mean bear in mind that a number of
monterey pines were planted at the same
time
uh before the house was there and of
these trees one apparently healthy one
failed catastrophically as he said in
march 2018
and another one has died and been
removed um
i i believe mr sample's been advised by
his expert that these trees are all of
the same vintage
and the two he's talking about are sort
of approaching their terminus
so whereas normally we want to let trees
um bow out in their own time i'm not
sure that's an option here
because a deterioration is a very clear
danger to the life and limb below it
um and i would wonder what the council's
liability would be if the
removal and pruning was refused uh while
we're aware of these factors
um the risk factor has been calculated
by mr sample's expert i believe
and i believe he's i don't know what the
exact figure is but i think he's put it
within a risk category that would
require remedial works
um if if that's the case i would think
we need to either question the
recommendations of the expert
and if we have no reason to do this we
should accept that it is a hazard
um given the situation of the tree above
the house which i think is
is actually an extraordinary case thanks
that's everything
thank you okay well i i think we've
we've got a
time constraint here before i mean
clearly there are certain issues that
still need to be
um sorted out as far as i can see um
i think mark woodham said that the
current um order expires i think it was
in a couple of days time and
members will note that the options
before us under six in the report is
either to confirm the order
unmodified to confirm the order in a
modified form
or to not confirm it and certainly i
wouldn't want
to not confirm any protection
in the sort of short term um because
clearly it needs to be demonstrated to
me
i feel that the trees if there is any
aspect of them that is unsound and works
need to be done
then that needs to be demonstrated by a
survey
actually involving the climbing uh and
not just from the ground as was outlined
by the
uh by mark rodhams so um
i feel that we'll need to have some sort
of
um uh order in place after the next
couple of days
uh so that those issues of um
concern can be further investigated but
i'll ask
i've got one other speaker wishing to
speak i'll ask them speak it's council
nutley
yeah thank you um yes i mean
we've had very similar bro similar
issues in in ashburton
where we had one of these trees crashed
down across some units
causing extensive damage um and there's
another tree that
i mean i've been on about this group of
trees for some time though
and they some have been removed there's
one remaining tree
that was recommended not to be fouled at
the time
they had an independent uh tree surgeon
inspect it and recommended that it
should be removed
and our people our tree officer
dominic scanlon has now agreed that it
is going to be removed
these trees are huge and like we're
saying in the vicinity where this
particular tree
that the objector is is mentioning um it
will
you know i i've based on this on
the loss of life and all the rest of it
which you know is quite feasible
um so as i say in in this case i mean i
would
i would go with the objector and say
that this tree needs to be removed
thank you all right there's two trees
but
anyway and councillor hook
thank you um i tend to go along with
your your opinion
um and you know i think we can all
sympathize with the um
uh the tree falling on your house and
having to move out and yeah
i'm sure really sympathize with that um
situation and the fear that the trees
that remain create but
my feeling is that um as you say chair
that we need to continue the protection
for now and then it's
um for the um mr sample to
demonstrate i believe can make another
application
for either felon or um pruning to deal
with any
um a situation that
the tree has or decay etc
um and that needs to be proven but for
the time being
we need to continue the protect the
immunity protection that is provided by
the tpo because these are significant
um trees in in the landscape thank you
thank you councillor bolovant thank you
i
i have concerns that the trees have an
expected lifespan of between 80 and 90
years and that's
available on the internet you can find
that if these trees are approaching
their age
and the history of failure on these
trees tends to be catastrophic
that yes you can survey it but in the in
the period between a survey and a
branch or a limb falling off the tree
failing
you don't know what's going on there are
significant risks associated with
allowing them to stand
past their expected lifespan and for
that reason
i would be in favor of allowing remedial
works or remove of that a tree if
necessary
okay well that that could happen even if
the tree was subject to the protection
and indeed it was
obviously subject to a conservation area
um application
so if it can be demonstrated the tree
is dangerous then obviously such works
could still happen
council mcgregor thank you chair
um in terms of the the
tree that failed previously and dropped
the limb that that tree
is noted by the uh tree officer um
as not being included in the
conservation order
so that tree could could by by
all reasonable means be removed from the
from the equation
trees themselves generally speaking you
can look at a tree you can climb a tree
you can
you can do whatever you like to it will
appear healthy and they can
drop a limb for a number of reasons they
can drop a limb from um
you know the weather being too dry the
weather being too wet
um the limb being too heavy you know
there are lots of reasons why
why trees drop limbs it doesn't
necessarily mean
that the whole tree is uh at risk
um and i think it's it's it's you know i
think you know in terms of council
nutley's point about the ones in ashburn
they had significant flaws in their
growth pattern
which meant that they had split trunks
at the base though they were a different
type of risk and this these trees
don't appear to follow that same pattern
so from my from my perspective
i would uh probably follow your lead on
this one chair
in terms of what you've suggested so far
and i think what we need to do is
perhaps look at this with a little bit
more detail
and a little bit more closely thank you
thank you
councilman
yes german uh i agree with the previous
speaker i
agree with your sentiments as well i
think we should
take uh steps to preserve this uh
these trees until we've done further
investigation
uh we've got our the views of our own
agriculturalist
i think we should listen to that and in
the meantime it's easy to chop a tree
down
once it's gone it's gone and there's
years of growth here
so i think we've got to be very careful
that we're doing the right thing all
round
so i'm very happy that that a tpo should
be put on it while further investigation
is done so
would you propose
yes i would i will propose that
okay so it's been proposed confirm the
tpo
unmodified i'd second that
mcgregor i was going to second that uh
okay thank you
right anyone else wishing to speak
nobody else in which case can i ask
chris to take the vote then please which
is
the first one on the list under options
and under six
that the the committee confirmed the tpo
unmodified chris
thank you chair councillor bradford i
don't know she's declared an interest
thanks council relevant four
tell us the clarence against
councillor colclough
hayes against
councillor hook
councillor jeffrey
counselor um sorry councillor kurzweil
four councillor mcgregor
four councillor nutley
bounce the nuttel against
councillor parker against councillor
patch
gates councillor goodman bradbury
four and councillor haynes
four
oh that's eight seven um chair in favor
yeah that's what i have written as well
so eight four seven again so that's
carried so
the tree preservation order is confirmed
unmodified
thank you that's uh item five
completed item six of course has been
um removed earlier which takes us on to
item seven the appeal decisions
for noting uh i think one particular
notable one there
anything that you wish to say on those
at all rise
um yes thank you chair um just to
note in particular the moorwood
application which is number one on the
list
which was the application for a
temporary uh
log cabin for um equine purposes so to
support a new business
a new equine business on the outskirts
of ipple pen
and that appeal was allowed and we also
had a cost award in relation
to that one and which i think the total
costs were in excess of seven thousand
pounds so i just wanted to
highlight that to members thank you so
members if you get a uh temporary um
request for temporary buildings for an
agricultural activity then you might
well be
worth your while looking back at the
details of that particular application
okay and as you heard costs awarded on
that one
okay i think the rest were fairly
straightforward and that was one that
the committee
overturned the officer recommendation
he'll note as well
right and that was in the days before we
had the recorded vote so
um obviously we can't remember it was
too long ago as to who who might have
voted which way
right um that then is there i'll have my
hand raised
oh sorry i didn't see it there yes just
forgot your comment about
on future applications and agricultural
use um
i don't i can can we have it confirmed
that
my belief was that equine use is
different from agricultural use
so the remarks you've made about future
uses applications for agricultural use
i'm not sure that
would apply in that case but perhaps we
could have some clarification
well i mean any future any future use
equine agriculture or whatever that you
might feel a bit dubious about all i was
suggesting was that you looked at that
appeal decision that's
that's all you know just to sort of in
some way inform what decision you come
to i didn't want to get into any
sort of nitty-gritty detail on that okay
okay all right okay thank you um the
other
person's got a hand up is uh oh no it's
gone
right okay nobody else wishing to to ask
anything on those
right in which case uh that's the end of
today's agenda so thank you all very
much and
i look forward to seeing you all in the
near future
okay so feel free to log off and cheerio
thank you
thank you thank you cheerio